hi Andrew hey how are you Madison I'm
great how are you thank you so much for
joining us
oh it's great to be here you're safe and
sound where are you physically I'm in
Tampa very safe and sound how are you
how come your family doing well you know
can't complain at all everyone's healthy
the kids are trying to learn by video
like a lot a lot of kids but you know
we're in an environment in upstate New
York where I can just walk outside and
go for a stroll if I want so I really
can't complain good I'm glad to hear
that and I want to give a quick intro to
our audience as they're joining us here
my name is Madison I'm a reporter with
Bloomberg News I'm joined here of course
by Andrew yang entrepreneur and former
presidential candidate Andrew thank you
again for making the time and for our
viewers who are watching I want to
remind you to comment with any questions
you have for Andrew we'll try to ask as
many as we can well while we have you
here
but first I'd love to start by just of
course starting by talking about
universal basic income I'm wondering if
you can share how kovat 19 has impacted
your thoughts on the implementation of
ubi this is a devastating time for so
many Americans and we just need to put
money into people's hands as quickly as
possible so I'm thrilled that today
Nancy Pelosi came out and said that we
need to consider universal basic income
dozens of members of Congress are
already now saying we need $2,000 a
month for everyone during this time what
I've been saying to people Madison is
that this crisis has in many ways
accelerated the rate of change where
we've gone through ten years of change
in the equivalent of 10 weeks or less
and so obviously I thought universal
basic income was a good idea even in the
absence of this crisis but it's more
urgent than ever it's literally life or
death for many many too far too many
Americans right now and you mentioned
politicians talking about universal
basic income but you really championed
the idea of UVI during your candidacy
I'm wondering what it feels like for you
to hear you know the president talking
about the implementation of a program
that's so close to your heart well I'm
just glad that they're using their kind
since because it's clear if you have
tens of millions of Americans trapped at
home with no income we're going to need
to get money into their hands my
frustration is around the fact that the
bulk of the stimulus has not gone to
families it's gone to big companies it's
gone to businesses that have private
bankers and have those relationships I
mean we saw the small business payment
protection program just run out of money
I have many many people telling me that
they're calling state unemployment
offices it's getting busy signal's and
never hearing back so I just wish we
were putting more money just directly
into people's hands but it's it's good
that we're at least doing what we are
doing I just wish that we treated our
people the same way we treat the biggest
companies absolutely and that brings me
to one question we got from an audience
member before we went live they asked if
you were in the White House right now
how would you be handling stimulus
checks well the first thing is you
shouldn't means-tested because there are
many Americans who are in position of
desperation right now but they made a
lot of money last year and I was talking
to a restaurateur who like it looked
good on paper but she is broke because
her restaurant obviously shut down and
she was trying to keep her employees
from going broken and facing really
difficult circumstances so she was like
why are they not like treating me like
everyone else we're like I really need
the $1,200 and she does and the fact is
we could have given it to everyone and
then just taking it back in next year's
tax returns if we felt like it so
there's no reason not to just give it to
everyone the universe of people that are
not getting it unfortunately the
millions of like tens of millions
because a lot of people don't follow tax
returns or they don't have auto pay or
their there's some issue so to me I
would be reversing the scales where
instead of like the vast majority going
to big businesses I would say the vast
majority should be going to people and I
would make it as universal as possible
even beyond certainly any level of
income but even whether or not you filed
a tax return if we can find you we
should be giving you enough money to get
by and this brings me to some of the
programs that you've launched in light
of kovat 19
one of them launched today can you
describe the all-americans movement and
your role in that so one of the tragic
outgrowths of this time is that racism
has surged towards different groups and
asian-americans have felt a new level of
fear and anxiety around the fact that
people blame us for the virus even
though we were a world away and you know
are just victims like anyone else so I
launched this all Americans campaign
today to saying look we're all in this
together all donations and purchases go
to Kovan relief and the crisis text line
to help people with the the anxiety and
fear that comes with this time and it's
it's just a really heartbreaking
phenomenon that in this crisis
unfortunately we're seeing black people
dying much higher levels in Michigan and
other parts of the country because of
pre-existing conditions and lower access
to health care but also racism against
Asian Americans has surged you're seeing
hundreds of reported assaults around the
country and so I thought I could do
something to help of course and you
mentioned on your podcast which launched
today that the crisis text line you
talked about it's surging right now can
you can you talk about that a bit I
talked to the CEO of the crisis text
line
Nancy Loveland who's awesome she's a
powerhouse so their traffic is doubled a
company-wide and which makes sense
because we're all stressed out and
anxious and there are a lot of people
suffering but then the proportion of
Asian Americans who've used the crisis
text line more than doubled on top of
the doubling it went from 5% of the
lower total to 13% of the higher total
and so I heard that and I said well that
that's heartbreaking because you have
people who were looking to hurt
themselves at much higher levels where
we had a mental health crisis before
that coronavirus and now we compounded
the anxiety and dress and isolation and
so the fact that the crisis text line is
traffic has doubled probably doesn't
surprise anyone listening to this but we
have to think about what the
implications are RN to the extent that
we can help we need to do all we can and
can you talk a little bit more
specifically about you know if you were
in the White House right now what would
you be doing to address the mental
health crisis in this country well the
first thing I would do because you have
to control what you can control
Madison so the first thing I would say
it's like look you do not need to worry
about your material needs putting food
on the table we're gonna distribute
money to everyone and you only need to
pay your bills your credit card company
your landlord the oil company can just
send us the government your bill and
we'll pay them for the duration of the
crisis because the fact is our
bureaucracy is not designed to get us
the money to like you know give to all
the people that we pay every month it's
highly flawed it's one of the reasons
why everyone's so anxious and pissed off
right now so if we if the government
just said look not on you will this pay
your bills we could have done that other
countries have done that so that would
have been the way I would try and lead
and say like this is one way you can put
people at ease and say hey you can
actually adhere to public safety and
health guidelines you can stay home you
don't need to worry about your bills for
this period of time and and if you're
struggling then we need to try and get
your resources even now so that's things
like the crisis text line but you have
to be realistic domestic violence is
surging right now child abuse the
surging right now so to the extent that
we have resources that can help with any
of those things we should just be honest
and say look we know these things are
surging and to the extent we can help
including at the high end even you know
trying to intervene in someone's like
household situation because some of
those situations are going to devolve
into very dangerous environments sure
and one program that you have worked on
that mirrors the solutions you're
talking about is project 100 which you
launched alongside Stacey Abrams can you
tell us about that program and how it's
getting funded project 100 is a
philanthropic effort to give a hundred
million dollars to a hundred thousand
food stamp recipients over the next
hundred days and I'm just thrilled to be
a part of it because our government
these again are not meeting everyone's
needs so a set of major philanthropists
the Schusterman Family Foundation Google
some really fun people like Rihanna and
think ariana grande and put some money
up and they're already at the vast
majority of this hundred million dollars
in a hundred days and being a part of
its privileged because we're improving
people's lives
I was just on CNN with Dominique one of
the recipients and she was a bartender
at an airport in Louisiana which clearly
does not operate she had not received
any stimulus because she didn't have a
tax return last year and project 100 got
her $1,000 and got her $1,000 within two
days of her pushing the button and
saying she needed help
wouldn't that be magic for us all like
imagine if you all had a button you
could press it $1,000 appears two days
later we're making that happen for tens
of thousands of Americans but the fact
is it should happen for all of us you
know like this should not be so
difficult and like we have the means to
put money into people's hands and
project 100 is demonstrating that that's
true and I think during your candidacy
some voters had questions about whether
funding for UB I would take funding away
from programs like Snap is project 100
partially your way of kind of putting
those concerns to bed that both things
can be funded equally well that's very
much on top of us to have benefits
that's for sure and I gotta say it's
been really fun because if you're a snap
recipient in one of these areas and then
a pop-up comes up and says hey you
wanted a thousand dollars they're like
what we got and then and they get it so
yeah like my goal was always to try and
build the floor that works for everyone
and then that doesn't mean we should be
reducing support for people in various
ways you know we should be trying to
solve people's problems particularly and
particularly in this time where it's
like like we have to face facts like
we're at great depression level
unemployment you have tens of millions
of Americans who lost their jobs though
there's a lower proportion of Americans
working right now than in our nation's
history so this is the time for big
Solutions and big advancements we don't
have a choice like we need a Marshall
Plan scale effort to rebuild this
country and everything needs to be on
the table like even things that I didn't
think we're great ideas I obviously
thought giving people money was a great
idea for you know since before the
crisis but anything we can do to help
get people into positive situations we
should do can you speak to that a little
bit more can you tell our audience a
couple of things that Cove in nineteen
is brought to your attention that could
be implemented as solutions well we're
in a crisis and one of the things I've
said to folks is like when the house is
on fire you don't worry about the amount
of water you're using and putting it out
so we've got a 21 trillion dollar fire
going on and youse need to do anything
you can to put it out so some of the
things I think we should be doing I
think we should just be like sending
money to every nonprofit that's doing
pretty much anything under the Sun
because like nonprofits you know their
support levels are plummeting all of
them cancel their fundraisers they're
cutting people do you really want
nonprofits like firing their people now
of all times so we should be taking any
organization that's doing anything
positive and just be just like put money
into their hands they're not firing
people same is definitely true of States
hospitals like you have to push on the
things you can push and one of the
reasons why I've always been so
passionate about universal basic income
is it's one of the few things you can
actually do very quickly and we just saw
it where Congress just conjured up now
it's like up to almost like 2.8 trillion
dollars and Counting because we're and
we're in the midst of a crisis imagine
if we had just made the same kind of
decision without a crisis where we just
looked up and said hey you know what we
should probably like try and get the
boot off of your throat and put some
money into your hands because the money
doesn't disappear in our hands anyway it
just goes right back in the economy it
goes to like local businesses and
restaurants they care tutoring services
so one reason why I love it so much is
that it's a tool that we know works that
you can use quickly now there are other
things that you need to do that are
equally important that are not
unfortunately as easy as money so that's
around healthcare infrastructure that's
around PPE that's around vaccines and
antibodies and tests
like why do we still have no tests
available in a lot of these areas you
know like in other countries they've had
drive-through testing I saw a story that
really just said it all where the
governor of Maryland managed to get his
hand on hands on like hundreds of
thousands of coded tests from South
Korea because like you had a
relationship and it's like that's what
we've been reduced to like the governor
of Maryland has to track and like do it
around go to South Korea like that the
fact that there's like right now a
competitive bidding war for PPE is
unconscionable it's like like does that
make any sense to anyone where you have
FEMA outbidding states outbidding each
other and so you know who's now getting
the the vital supplies Louisiana
Mississippi places that are poor and
guess what that's where the public
health threat from the corona virus is
highest because you have low levels of
health care infrastructure and very high
levels of pre-existing conditions
absolutely and you've mentioned the
unemployment rate a few times during
your campaign you talked a lot about
joblessness in the face of automation
which has been put on hyperspeed with
this pandemic you know your solution be
to the unemployment rate in this country
so I just want to make a couple of big
points that everyone should bear in mind
number one is many of these millions of
jobs have been lost are never coming
back and I'm just going to use an
example that we can all understand
Macy's furloughed most of their hundred
30,000 employees how many of those
employees you think Macy's gonna bring
back over the next six eight months 100%
of course not they're a bunch of stories
that were borderline anyway that they
were like looking at closing the big
company CEOs are completely investing in
automation and software to try and get
things done without as many people I
know this in part cuz they're like
telling telling friends of mine that
that's exactly what they're doing I mean
they're not gonna come out and say be
like hey I'm gonna take advantage of
this crisis to like automate my
processes but that is exactly what they
are doing so we have to face facts this
economy is not going to be like a rubber
band that snaps into place
many of these jobs are gone for good so
now you have this nation rebuilding
question of like how the heck do
ploy all these people this is we're
putting money into our hands comes in
this is we're putting money into small
businesses and nonprofits and into giant
public works into infrastructure into
sustainable sustainable development into
a healthcare workforce where hundreds of
thousands of workers short on people who
can even do testing so we need to hire
as many people as we need and so so if
you imagine there's like this giant hole
like now it's going to be up to us to
fill it and the government should be
doing everything in its power to help
other people have the resources they
need to hire but then in some cases
actually hire people for tasks that are
necessary absolutely and I want to go to
some audience questions we're getting
great questions and so thank you all for
commenting one audience member asks what
do you think the new normal will look
like after the pandemic so I you know I
try and avoid the new normal in part
because so we had I guess you'd call
what happened pre-pandemic as like
normal let's let's say and then that
there's this sense that the pandemic is
gonna push us one way and then we're
going to somehow snap the other way and
that will be the new normal it's like
the way a lot of us think the truth is
that there's like tremendous havoc being
wreaked on individuals families
businesses organizations around the
country and the new normal in the
absence of any massive intervention on
our part is just less functional more
damaged less entrepreneurial less robust
it's just a wreck like if you ask me
what do you think the new normal will
look like in the absence of massive
intervention the new normal will be like
a shambles frankly and so the question
is how do you prevent that from being
what we are faced with that is to me why
you need a massive Marshall scale
Marshall Plan scale initiative and like
it or not the only entity that has the
resources necessary to do that kind of
work at that scale is the federal
government so when you ask me what is
the new normal
like it's a it's a wreck it's a mess
it's a shambles unless we put literally
trillions of dollars to work trying to
make it something better and do you
think the implementation of a VAT tax
would still be your recommendation even
moving past the Coppa 19 pandemic well
we need to get resources into our hands
and if you have companies hastening
automation which you do have so let's
say I'm a company and I replace
thousands of call center workers with
software now the call center worker is
used to pay taxes the software does not
and you have the biggest most successful
companies of our age Amazon Netflix
Starbucks literally paying zero in
corporate taxes right now because the
corporate income tax is really easy to
gain so the question is they just move
it to Ireland especially if they're
multinational they say like add like
nothing to see here so you need a
mechanism where we get some of those
gains and my proposal was a value-added
tax which would get those gains I think
that would be a very effective way that
to me is the big challenge is that you
have to recognize how dysfunctional our
current corporate tax system is and then
change it so that the amazons of the
world are not paying zero in taxes think
about that Amazon trillion our company
hiring hundred thousand people zero in
taxes while everyone else heads indoors
and you mentioned big tech and want to
talk a little bit about user privacy
I've been wondering if we move into this
Universal push for tracing the virus how
will that impact user privacy not only
now but moving past the pandemic this is
a very big problem an issue where I'm
going to just tell the story from my
family a cousin of mine landed in China
a number of weeks ago and she was then
tested at the airport escorted tour
apartment the monitor was put on her
apartment she was told to stay there for
two weeks and then a government employee
came every day to check on her make sure
she hadn't gone anywhere and take her
temperature now
if you're in America you hear that that
sounds dystopia but would that help stem
like your concern about someone that's
coming from another environment and then
just walking around in fact alone
so that is really going to be the kind
of trade-off we make where in China
they're they they actually are going to
have you scan QR codes just to go into a
public place that the relay your data
and you you get color coded based upon
your you know level of risk and then if
you're green you can go in if you're red
you can now how the heck do they
determine if you're red or green based
on a lot of data that they've been like
rocky and if it turns out that you're
infected later they can figure out who
you were around like contact tracing is
a very highly laborious process really
difficult and if you're going to reopen
any part of the economy and you're going
to do it you would need to have some
robust tech tracing and tracking tools
and those things run afoul of what most
of us regard as like our privacy rights
because it's like I don't want you to
know if I go to the freaking grocery
store now there's actually a public
health benefit of mine knowing if you
went to the grocery store because it
turns out someone else in that grocery
store was sick like we can be like hey
fYI like you know so so this is the
massive trade off we need to make and we
need to say to people look like if you
want to get out of this crisis faster
we're gonna need some information about
you and different Americans gonna have
different responses to that but this is
the kind of conversation we need to be
having if we're going to actually get
this virus under control
moving forward because you have to know
that this thing might recur and not to
make this like the black mirror section
of the interview but do you envision
there being any sort of immune class
structure that evolves out of this
pandemic I think that if we're
successful at reopening parts of the
economy we're gonna have to have a much
more robust testing infrastructure in
place and so that if you're going
someplace and getting tested
you know that you're like alright you're
safe other people are safe one component
of that might be like do I have the
antibodies if it turns out that if
you've had it before that you're you
know resistant and then can you document
that and so there are going to be people
who have either resistance or tests you
know clean or access to tests that will
have more liberty than others
at least in certain environments so I
think that is what I'm just describing
would look like progress honestly
because right now we don't have the
tests and we don't have the ability to
even give you like like any kind of
documentation that you may be resistant
so so that in some ways might actually
be like a positive step if we got to a
point where you could actually show that
you're low risk so it sounds like you're
saying there is a bit of a trade-off
that you would land on the side of
potentially giving up some privacy in
the name of ending the virus I think
that is the right approach if we're
going to reopen parts of the economy
because you have to be realistic right
now we're in the mitigate community
spread phase which is quite extreme you
know it involves most of us being at
home and we may be at this for 18 months
and so is it realistic to have everyone
maximally like stay at home for 18
months it's like it's not so then if
you're going to reopen parts of the
economy then you need data you need
testing and part of that is us sharing
information sure and Andrew I want to
end by I know you only have a couple
minutes left with us a lot of our
audience has questions of course about
your political future I'm wondering if
Joe Biden wins the White House what
cabinet position would you potentially
see yourself in that's nice of people to
be to be interested in my future of I
you know I I think Trump's a disaster
like I'm very eager to help Joe win at
the White House and and when Joe wins
if he taps me for a high-impact position
in this administration I'd obviously be
very open to it I'm passionate about
many issues that I ran on liked ones
obviously universal basic income but
another one is the impact of technology
on our way of life I think that our
government has been decades behind the
curve on many technology issues and
that's gone from inconvenient to
disastrous over time and if there's
something I can do to help accelerate
our government I would I would give that
sort of role a very very long look and
you've also hinted at running for mayor
of New York City if you choose to follow
through with that you'd be inheriting a
very different New York after this
crisis what would your plan potentially
look like to revitalize the city New
York is going to have a very very deep
hole to dig out of and and it hurts me
because I love New York and in terms of
what we need to do I mean again you have
to try and reopen parts of the economy
and to do that you need tests you need
consumer confidence so my first order of
business would be to try and make sure
that if you're going to school if you're
going to a hospital you're going to work
that you know that you're going to be
safe and if you can accomplish that then
you can actually look at trying to
re-energize parts of the city but it's
going to be a long road back and it
makes me very sad like it's not gonna be
again that's one reason why like you
talked about the new normal
New York City is going to be one of the
hardest hit
urban areas from this crisis for a long
time to come
absolutely and we've talked a lot about
how it is just such a hard and saddening
time but you are so widely known by all
of your staffers to be such a joyful and
positive person tonight so nice to hear
ound truth that campaign staffers have
said about you so I'm wondering how are
you keeping that attitude up during
quarantine Madison thanks to the P
people who supported my campaign I feel
like I can help people you know and like
I'm in a position we're all suffering in
different ways in the sense that you
know like I haven't met my niece like
you know my my kids aren't going to see
their grandparents for months and months
on end but I still count myself very
very lucky and I need to help if you
have the capacity to help right now you
need to help and thanks to the folks who
supported me I feel like I'm in that
category but if you'd like to help you
know one way to do so is through my
organization move humanity forward calm
but there are dozens of organizations
out there that you can get involved with
please do step up come together help
your your fellow Americans because
everyone needs it right now and that
this crisis is a very very challenging
time but it's going to show what we're
made of and I hope that we can show that
in a very very positive way and Andrew
we have just one or two minutes left
here I want to ask how was it for you
going from campaigning and being in
countless cities to being under
quarantine
you know what advantage to it is that I
missed my kids a lot and I've learned a
lot about my kids now they went from
having too little dad maybe a little bit
too much so so that's been a bright side
that like at least I'm getting family
time that I've missed out on the last
couple years I missed my my kids a great
deal of two boys were four and seven one
of whom was autistic and my wife Evelyn
has been such a rock star and rock to
the family so being able to spend time
with them has been one of the few
positives to come out of this time and I
also just wanted to ask you about
homeschooling I'm wondering if you think
enough is being done to help parents who
are having a home school children of
varying neurological abilities during
this quarantine III just want to shout
out every teacher every daycare worker
every parent because even if you have
your kid plugged into the laptop and you
know they just wander off you know it's
like yeah yeah I mean the kids gonna do
so so most every parent is juggling
different jobs I think I speak for many
many parents around the country where we
are very eager for schools to reopen
because there are lot of things that
kids need that you get through being in
class being in school being with other
people that you can't get from a laptop
that's just my perspective I know there
are many people who love the distance
learning aspect I think that that I'm
just more appreciative of my kids
teachers every day absolutely well
Andrew thank you so much for your time
and thank you to our audience for
joining and commenting with all your
questions we really appreciate it Thank
You Madison stay awesome stay healthy
much